dying on-screen poses a unique challenge
for an actor but some are more
accustomed to it than others
in fact some stars seem like they died
during just about every movie they're in
grab a shovel and join us for a look at
a few of Hollywood's finest fake dead
people spoilers ahead also some not very
pleasant looking movie massacres samuel
l.jackson for a guy who's made an
excellent living playing and posing
characters samuel l.jackson seems to
meet his maker in the movies on a
surprisingly regular basis this has more
than a little to do with the law of
averages simply put when you make over
100 films you're bound to be called upon
for your share of death scenes but
Jackson's many movie deaths over 20 and
all and still growing include some a
modern cinemas most memorable character
exits like in Goodfellas Jurassic Park
and true romance but our favorites
there's the time he was suddenly
slaughtered by a shark in deep blue sea
and sent plummeting to his death by evil
Emperor Palpatine and Revenge of the
Sith
Gary Busey's character actor and
real-life character Gary Busey has died
on screen more than 20 times and we're
pretty sure he's the only actor to be
killed to the cameras by Dolly Parton
ice-t and Snoop Dogg other memorable aw
things have come courtesy of his roles
in Lethal Weapon predator 2 and point
brainy Lance Henriksen one of the most
prolific murder victims in movie history
Lance Henriksen has had the honor of
being offed by some pretty heavy hitters
he died in the Terminator aliens and
alien vs. predator as well as one of the
many Hellraiser sequels
it's hard to pick a favorite from
Henrickson's list of more than 30 deaths
but ours might be the barely remembered
jean-claude Van Damme movie hard target
in which Henrickson's character has a
grenade shoved down his pants John
Hurt's obviously plenty of esteemed
actors have bit the big one in multiple
movies but John Hurt takes cinematic
corpse hood to another level not only is
he compiled more screen deaths than
arguably any other actor over 40 and all
including contact Hellboy and V for
Vendetta
but the oscar-nominated legend also
boasts one of the most memorable exits
of all time he was the first victim of a
chest burster an alien suffering a gory
demise that's made millions of
moviegoers jump screaming out of their
seats Sean Bean John Dean's tendency for
playing doomed characters is so well
known that it's inspired its own website
countless memes and a number of in-depth
analytical studies to determine whether
he has in fact died on screen more than
any other actor we'll leave that to the
number crunchers suffice it to say we've
watched bean pass away more times than
we or he can count like in Goldeneye
patriot games and of course Game of
Thrones he said to the Daily Mail maybe
it's the quality of my death people are
fascinated by I liked Lord of the Rings
Nicholas Cage in real life we suspect
Nicolas Cage might be immortal but at
the movies he's done commonly
susceptible to memorably messy deaths
he took a stake through the chest in
vampire's kiss drank himself to death in
leaving Las Vegas was burned to a crisp
in kick-ass just to name a few but no
matter how many times he dies on screen
our favor will always be the insane way
he perishes in the all-around crazy 2006
remake of The Wicker Man before that
movie came along we'd never have guessed
we needed to see Kage punch a woman
while wearing a bear suit or watch him
howl and over-the-top agony while having
his face covered with bees
now that we've seen it our lives will
never be the same
Johnny Depp Johnny Depp's distinguished
career includes over a dozen killer
moments including his electrocution at
the hands of Charlize Theron and the
astronauts wife and being eaten by the
Kraken and Pirates of the Caribbean Dead
Man's Chest his best movie death however
will probably always be his first in the
original Nightmare on Elm Street Depp's
character is going down into his bed
after falling asleep sending a gushing
fountain the blood spraying up into the
room after he's gone
even in a franchise known for its
spectacular death scenes it remains a
standout Michael Biehn after a while it
got to the point where as soon as you
saw Michael beans face on screen you
started counting down the minutes until
his inevitable death he's arguably the
most important victim in the Terminator
he's imploded in the abyss and he's shot
in the forehead by Val Kilmer and
tombstone and those are just the RIT
highlights from his first 10 years in
the movies he's gone on to the great
beyond more than 20 times but our
favorite might be the crowbar he took to
the head and stiletto a little scene
2008 effort featuring castle star stana
katic Danny Trejo Danny Trejo seems like
one of the few Hollywood stars who could
legitimately handle himself in a violent
life-or-death situation
but he's been on the losing end and more
than a few mortal movie conflicts during
his career early on he was often called
on as cannon fodder in action films
dying at the hands of Charles Bronson
and death wish for and being blown up in
the Gary Busey flick bulletproof bodies
graduated to more exotic deaths in more
recent years cemetry knows more
memorable exits include his grisly
demise and predators but for us his best
death scene will always be the poignant
mercy kill in courtesy of Robert De Niro
in Michael Mann's classic 1995 action
thriller heat Bruce Willis never mind
die hard for much of his career Bruce
Willis's mantra seems to have been die
often his dozen Plus on-screen deaths
have included crucial turning points in
movies like 12 monkeys and the jackal
and it was his character who had the
honor of saving the planet by being
blown up on an asteroid in Armageddon
he's also had a couple of really stylish
deaths courtesy of Robert Rodriguez and
Quentin Tarantino biting the dust in Sin
City and grindhouse
his greatest death might be his most
mind-blowing namely the sneaky way he
biffed dust in the sixth sense but when
he dies as a result of a time paradox in
the 2012 sci-fi classic looper that one
might be our favorite thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know which other actors should
have made the list